[Musique]
tu viun moitié tu fais la coupe et après
tu vides tout et tu mets tout dans une
caisse et on paèse quand même et tu fais
peut-être un prélèvement
dessous comm et les deux poteaux qui
traînent tu te rappelles 8
oui le cercle le
[Applaudissements]
cercle les minutes aussi
su
la per pH il ont pris la
perche note
ouais on est sur une opération
préventive qui est extrêmement vaste
puisqu'on a eu l'occasion de traiter 15
hectares ce qui est une superficie
colossale on est sur un tracé routier
donc on est forcément sur un linéaire
qui fait plusieurs
kilomètres là il y aura une route
exactement OK et nous on intervient
juste avant la construction de la route
pour bah sauvegarder une grande partie
des données archéologiques et une fois
qu'on aura terminé bah la route pourra
se faire sans aucun souci on sera parti
avec toutes les informations ça vous
l'avez fait cette année cette année ou
ça c'était février février jusqu'à juin
ça pendant l'été juillet-août et puis ça
on a commencé fin juin et puis là on va
terminer fin octobre début novembre
comme c'est extrêmement vaste on a dû
subdiviser ça en plusieurs zones parce
qu'il était difficile d'Inter venir sur
tout le tronçon en même temps ça aurait
nécessité 50 personnes des pelles
mécaniques partout c'était difficile à
gérer donc on a fait ça en en trois
zones et puis on se trouve désormais sur
le secteur 3 qui correspond au plateau
de la pancarte où là on est de nouveau
en surplom de l'Erdre et où on a une vue
directe sur la zone qu'on a fouillé au
au début de l'année et donc là du coup
la zone actuelle elle a pas du tout la
même forme que les autres non parce que
là on a un échangeur ah ce qui explique
la forme l'échangeur et puis la route
qui va rejoindre le rond-po et puis les
résultats scientifiques sont hyper
intéressants puisqu'on se retrouve à
avoir une fenêtre
ouverte sur Nord surde qui est qui est
qui est colossale pour l'âge du bronze
qui est une période pour laquelle on a
assez peu d'information en Loir
Atlantique donc là d'avoir pour l'âge du
bronze des sites d'habitat des
structures funéraires tout ça sur un
même tracé avec des sites qui se font
face il va y avoir beaucoup de choses à
raconter dans le rapport et
scientifiquement les apports vont être
vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chouette ça c'est le plan du tracé
routier ouais
la totalité avec en noir c'est les
tranchées de
diagnostic on été été
réalisé vous avez pu en faire beaucoup
ou il pas mal c'est le département c'est
le Service archéologique du département
qui a fait les tranché de diagnosti et
ensuite bah c'est les plans des zones de
fouille sur papier mais c'est un peu
petit ça c'est le plan de la zone en
face ouais donc avec les grosses fusses
que j'évoqué tout à l'heure ici qui sont
plutôt lié à des rejets ou artisanat
d'accord ce qui est moutarde un peu
verre ouais et puis des plantes de
bâtiment assez vastes qu'on
peut interpréter comme de possibles
habitations et puis à côté de ça des
plans de bâtiments beaucoup plus petits
qui sont plutôt liés au stockage et du
coup ça c'est un bâtiment quoi en terre
et bois ouais pour ces périodes là ouais
c'est des des pieux à à la verticale un
clayonnage torchi on est à peu près
certain de
de ces restitutions parce que
régulièrement dans les fauxes ancrages
de poteau on a des fragments de torchie
ça ça daterait de quand là on est sur du
Bronze final ouais 1300 800 en gros
et pour certains bâtiments comme ici on
a carrément une ligne de poteau en
partie centrale et quand on est
confronté à ça on imagine que ces
poteaux au centre ils servent à
supporter une poutre fétière et qu'on a
donc une toiture à double
[Musique]
pente
et ouais là c'est pareil on a les pieux
on a toujours les aménagementhizontal et
puis des petites baguettes en fait qui
sont disposé à l'horizontale dans le
détail ça donne ça il y a le pie
vraiment à la verticale qui est enfoncé
et puis les aménagements
transversaux c'est un petit aménagement
de berge alors on sait pas si c'est un
petit penton pour la pêche pour venir
àoster une embarcation
autre
chose l'aménagement de berge il est
vraiment là où il a les petits doigts de
la main ah ouais et l'Erdre fait ça ah
oui d'accord l'Erdre c'est vraiment au
niveau des des arbres ici
ok donc les pieux voilà à quoi peuvent
ressembler on est vraiment sur des pieux
travaillés euh avec des pointes qui sont
durcies au feu ah ou
ouais alors ce qui est intéressant quand
même c'est en terme de datation c'est
qu'il y a pas de clous d'accord quand il
y a des clous euh on a tendance à dire
bah c'est récent puisque l'utilisation
des crou VO la par hisori ouais voilà
c'est ça il y a des boises travaillé des
échancrures et des choses qui s'enchasse
on a espoir que ce soit un peu ancien
ouais et après on arrive sur la zone
antique ah oui avec le double fossé là
qui revient ici ouais
euh et puis qui délimite un espace
habité à
l'Antiquité on a pas mal de plans de
bâtiments qui se sont dessinés et PU
ensite on arrive sur le grand plateau
que vous avez ici où on a quelques plans
de bâtiment qui qui on été reconnu la
base de fouille
là
d'accord c'est beaucoup plus dense c'est
plus on voit que tout se passe tout se
passe là
[Musique]
quoi lors du diagnostic on avait que des
vestiges d'habitat et depuis le début on
fouille que vestiges d'habitat donc des
bâtiments des fausses tout ce qui est
lié vraiment à une vie quotidienne et le
fait d'avoir une une architecture
funéraire pas si loin que ça de
l'habitat ça pose beaucoup de questions
et nous on a hâte d'avoir des éléments
de datation précis pour pouvoir
mettre C cet aménagement en relation
avec le reste est-ce que ce sont les
gens qui habitaent ici qui ont construit
le monument pour déposer leur mort
est-ce que ce sont les gens qui étaient
de l'autre côté de l'Erdre au quel cas
il y a une visibilité directe puisque si
on imagine un petit tumulus on est sur
quelque chose qui marque dans le paysage
donc d'en face voilà on voit très bien
ce qui se passe en face donc faut se
dire qu'à l'époque c'était très
vraisemblablement la même chose donc là
nous tout ce qui nous reste en fait
c'est les fossées périphériques donc
c'est vraiment juste le tour c'est
vraiment la forme comme on connaît ce
type de forme par ailleurs ou dans
d'autres endroits on va avoir la
sépulture conservée on on peut sans trop
extrapoler voilà proposer l'hypothèse
d'e d'une structure funéraire on peut
imaginer du coup il y en a d'autres ça
send ouais il y a de grandes Chan ouais
ouais c'est rarement des choses qu'on va
retrouver isoler ça peut fonctionner en
petite nécropole et le problème qui se
pose ici c'est qu'on est vraiment juste
dans le coin de l'emprise donc peut-être
que ça se poursuit dans le champ d'un
côté peut-être que ça se poursuit
derrière malheureusement nous tout ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire c'est travailler
sur les photos aériennes
anciennes donc nous fait le relevé de ce
qu'on a fouillé et en plan et en coupe
ce qui nous permet de voir un peu
comment ça s'organise pasement tout ce
qu'on a c'est des petits bout des petit
tesson de céramique pour l'instant qui
permettront peut-être de dire que c'est
âge du bronze voilà on fait des
prélèvements de charbon pour faire du
C14 dedans pour dater plus précisément
tu aime bien un peu de faire le dessin
technique ouais c'est chouette ouais bah
oui ça c'est ça montre ce que tu as
compris de ta fouille en fait donc bah
il y a différentes étapes en fait dans
notre travail et c'est c'est bien de
tout faire pour tout comprendre hein et
on va au bout des choses parce que juste
sa structure c'est bien mais faire son
tamisage
derrière penser faire des petits bouts
de rapport des petites descriptions de
la rédaction bah oui tu tu vas au bout
du process et là tu es contente tu
comprends ce que tu fais tu fais quoi ce
matin du coup auourd'hi aujourd'hui je
vais faire la topo que tous les clous
qu'on a qui permett de délimiter nos
structures je les prendre en top petit
machin et comme ça on aura un
[Musique]
plan
as une idée du nombre
de alors je peux vous dire le nombre de
points qu'on a qu'on a pris depuis le
début on
a on a 759 points pour l'instant donc
moi j'ai j'ai pris mon GPS et puis j'ai
pris 759 points depuis le début du
chantier ça c'est t nos clous clous il
nous permettent attends tu peux rester
sur juste les clous h vous les enlever
après les clous ouais il faut qu'on la
zone donc tout ce qui est euh B ça c'est
déjà fait mais tout tous les clous qu'on
a sur no sur notre terrain faudra tout
dépolluer dépolluer on appelle ça
dépolluer enlever
toute tout ce qu'on a mis sur le site et
puis en fait nous on est censé remettre
le terrain dans l'état où on l'a trouvé
donc à chaque structure vous l'avez vu
on met des clous pour pour sur notre
dessin les symboliser et puis savoir les
remettre dans l'espace les clous sont
représenté par les croin rougge c'est
pour ça on prend les points pour avoir
l'altitude et ensuite on la met sur le
dessin pour avoir l'altitude minimale et
à partir de ça retrouver des bâtiments
parce que si s'il y a des creusements
qui sont au même altitude ça peut nous
aider à à d un bâtiment h parce que du
coup ça c'est des données numériques
donc il y a toujours une chance qu'on
les perde donc on a et on a toujours les
données papiers donc voilà c'est des
choses qu'on double donc ça c'est des
choses qu'on qu'on donnera au service
régional d'archéologie he pour il les
archives ouais pour l'archiver ouais
donc on on essaie de faire tout propre
ouais on met bien toutes les données
qu'on a donc le numéro de la fouille
l'endroit parce que c'est des choses
enfin nous on le voit quand on fait des
quand on étudie des fouilles anciennes
c'est mieux c'est fait plus c'est facile
après pour les archéologues du futur et
oui pour étudier si jamais au papier VO
ouis donc voilà on a toutes nos données
c'est trop
chouette on met notre structure on fait
un plan et on fait une coupe ah et vous
notez quand même vos premières
impression enfin vos fait ouais c'est
que on décrit le plan de notre structure
et ensuite on décrit les différents
comblements donc ce qu'on voilà là on a
du sable gris homogène hétérogène la la
dureté peu compacte
compacte et en plus et ensuite ce qu'on
trouve dedans voilà des inclusions voilà
des des caillou de quartz et puis
d'éventuell découverte archéologique ah
ouais donc là il y a du
charbon souvent ensemble ouaisous ah
vous êtes une équipe ouais on on est un
peu une équipe ouais on a un petit
groupe de quatre qui fonctionne ensemble
c'est les néo en fait Kevin Fabien et
Audrey néo les néolithiqu c'est le
groupe néo de la base d' bonhomme mon
insecte
c'est de Néo
euh le rouge le bleu certains certains
nous confidèrent quand une se
ouais on est tout le temps ensemble sur
tous les sites on y va ensemble à chaque
fois et sur ce chantier to depuis le
début ouais je suis depuis leouais je
suis depuis février ouais ça fait quoi
de dear c'est la fin de un chantier si
long on est un peu content en fait parce
qu'on commence à en avoir un peu un peu
marde on a envie d'aller étudier
maintenant on envie de comprendre ce
qu'on en partie le site du coup euh
ouais je pense qu'on a tous envie
d'aller en poste fouille donc euh on a
des trous de poteau qui font des fois 50
cm des fois 20 cm donc il faut essayer
au au milieu de bah de toute la forêt de
de trous d'identifier ce qui peut
fonctionner ensemble et donner un plan
cohérent pour un édifice pour restituer
un édifice parce que c'est ce qu'on
recherche après il y a sans doute à
terme de d'autres plans de de bâtiment
qui vont ressortir en poste ou
ouais peut-être une spécialisation des
activités aussi qui va s'observer avec
peut-être la présence de graines dans
certaines structur alors qu'elles seront
absentes dans
d'autres nous on prélève des sauts de
sédiments vous l'avez vu sans doute sur
le terrain on va les tamiser alors
parfois ça permet de récupérer des
charbons de bois quand il y en a donc
pour la datation c'est pas mal ça nous
donne des infos sur les activités mais
aussi sur les pratiques alimentaires les
pratiques
agricoles donc c'est tout ce qui est
ressorti de la fouille donc c'est c'est
pas énorme par rapport à la densité
enfin la denensité mais par rapport à la
taille du chantier qu'on a quand même 15
hectares ouais mais voilà ça donne une
idée mais quand même enfin il y a une
quantité de ENF ça monte
jusqu'ici que c'est du petit matérielou
là c'est les céramiques là c'est les
pièces lithiques qui sont dans les
caisses c'est pas un chantier antique
vous avez pas sorti des des caisses
d'enfor qui prent de la place du coup
bah les charbons qui vont être prélevés
on va peut-être les envoyer en analyse
pour des C14 moi je trouve ça super de
voir ça parce que on se rend compte de
la minutie vraiment tout est étiqueté
tout est rangé tout à sa place même hier
Kevin il a ouvert son sur son ordi tous
ces dossiers oui tout est classé enfin
évidemment parce qu'il y a tellement
d'infos que si si c'est mal rangé c'est
c'est perdu en c'est et le numéro de
structure qu'on a sur la fouille il va
jusqu'à la fin enfin il va jusqu'au
sachet jusqu'au ton de
céramique cette céramique rapport à nous
elle a 3000 ans parce que c'est de la
céramique de l'âge du bronze
potentiellement plus de l'âge du Bronze
final donc on est sur une période assez
large qui dure entre 1300 et 800 avant
Jésus-Christ bah les étapes c'est une
fois que c'est étalé c'est déjà de de
différencier par type de pâte là pour
chaque sachet je vais faire des petits
tas euh pour un peu essayer de mettre
ensemble les pâtes qui me semblent
cohérentes donc là je vais faire ça là
on a deux éléments qui peuvent avoir une
pâte un peu similaire mais en fait c'est
pas les mêmes formes donc je sais que ça
c'est un bol et ça c'est un pot donc je
vais les mettre séparément et je vais
faire des petits tas comme ça pour voir
euh si je peux avoir des groupes de
pâtes qui se qui se
distingue et qui peuvent en fait me
faciliter le montage par la suite une
fois que mes tas sont faits je vais
essayer de voir si euh par corrélation
de type de pâte je peux recoller
euh ce fragment là
euh si je le mets comme ça en fait c'est
le même vase d'accord voilà donc c'est à
peu près la même pâte donc je vais
essayer de faire ce remontage là pour un
peu tous les vases et je pense que bah
celui-là ce gros fragment là va sûrement
aller avec ce type de pâte
là et là par exemple on a un vase qui
est beaucoup plus petit beaucoup plus
fin c'est un vraiment un haut enfin
c'est on a le bord du vase là et là faut
s'imaginer peut-être soit un petit
gobelet ou alors une Poupelle peut-être
voilà par exemple là est il y a ça
cololle donc
voilà tu fais ça
vite du coup pourant j'ais pas trop ça
quand j'étais petite
pourquoi on en retrouve beaucoup sur les
sites c'est que ça se dégrade peu dans
le sol ça se casse et par contre ça va
pas se dégrader tant que ça on va avoir
différents types de pâtes là on va avoir
des pâtes qui vont être avec des gros
grains de quarz des gros grains de mica
qui vont un peu briller et par contre on
va avoir des pâtes qui vont être très
fine avec très peu d'inclusion en fait
de grain de quartz ou de Mik et ça ça
peut être un geste volontaire des
population et du potier euh tout
simplement parce que il y a différents
usages
ser à différentes choses les céramiques
enfin les les récipients là on va
sûrement être face à un vase qui a servi
peut-être à la consommation ou la
présentation des denrées alimentaires
celui-là euh ça peut correspondre à une
jar un peu plus grosse ça peut être pour
le stockage mais ça peut aussi servir
pour des réserves d'eau euh voilà on
peut imaginer aussi ça donc là mon
travail ça va être aussi de d'essayer de
noter toutes ces traces que je peux voir
est-ce qu'on va retrouver beaucoup de
vases de stockage ou de Cu puiss son
dans une structure et du coup ça va
peut-être pouvoir informer bah les
archéologues qui ont travailler sur le
site s'il y avait une zone
préférentielle de stockage ici par
exemple à contrario si je retrouve
beaucoup de vases à d'aspect beaucoup
plus fin et beaucoup plus lisse là
peut-être qu'on était plutôt sur un sur
un endroit il y avait plutôt de la
consommation alimentaire ou une maison
un habitat à côté
quoi
tu fais quoi là alors là j'utilise le
conformateur
c'est de prendre le profil de la
céramique de manière précise et juste
surtout donc je j'applique en fait
j'pplique j'applique en fait le
conformateur sur sur le la céramique et
le bâton en bois me sert juste à bien
appuyer en fait les lame sur le
conformateur une fois que c'est
fait du coup je vais redessiner en
fait le profil sur mon papier millimétré
on peut utiliser aussi papier calque ça
dépend des habitudes de chacun
donc là j'ai le
profil que je reprends un peu pour qu'il
soit bien visible et ensuite je vais
utiliser un pied à coulisse pour mesurer
en fait l'épaisseur du vase à plusieurs
endroits et faire la même chose en fait
pour l'autre face du vase reporter le
profil interne du coup sur mon
dessin mais j'ai j'ai un autre alors
pour le diamètre des vases après j'ai ça
c'est ça va permettre en fait de
restituer le diamètre d'ouverture du
vase donc je vais appliquer le vase sur
sur ce diamétron et je vais essayer de
voir là c'est pas mal donc là on est à
11 en rayon donc faut s'imaginer
potentiellement je vais essayer de 12
peut-être plutôt 12 on est sur un rayon
de 12 cm donc ça fait un diamètre de 24
cm et donc là je le note je le note en
fait
sur sur mon
dessin tu fais ça pour chaque Tessin euh
pour chaque vase présentant une forme
intéressante pas pour chaque t donc là
par exemple je vais le refaire pour euh
pour
celui-là c'est génial de de penser qu'on
pose de du projet de construction
d'une départementale à à ça quoi au
diamètre d'un vase c'est ça au diamètre
d'un vase
ouais
le gros à priori qu'ont les gens et on
peut les comprendre parce que la
législation est complexe c'est de se
dire ah il y a des fouilles ça coince
tous les travaux ça va retarder tout
c'est pas le cas et quand les projets se
montent l'aspect le volet archéologie il
est prévu à la fois dans le budget et
dans le délai alors s'il y a pas de
fouille et ben tant mieux il gagne du
temps mais s'il y a une fouille de toute
façon elle est prévue dans le planning
initial là pour pour cette route
l'archéologie faisait partie du planning
initial puisque c'était une éventualité
j'imagine que sur 8 mois comme ça plus
la Poste fouille combien ça coûte au
fond une un geste archéologique comme ça
bah là on est sur du très long alors le
chiffre va vous paraître énorme on est
entre 2 et 3 millions d'euros ah oui ça
m'étonne pas ouais mais parce que on est
resté bah 9 mois à 15 les moyens
mécaniques c'est le plus gros poste de
dépense
euh ça c'est sûr les le mécanique coûte
très cher après il y a effectivement les
humains qu'il faut payer
déplacer nourrir il y a les
installations de chantier et puis il y a
aussi tout ce qui va être après alors
outre les humains qui va falloir
financer dans le cadre de la Poste
fouille des datations par le
radiocarbone des analyses palinologiques
des analyses
d'androchronologiques bah tout ça mis
bout à bout à la fin euh çaent plusieurs
années en fait ah oui oui complètement
ouais é aller sur sur 3 ans à l'échelle
du projet global c'est
rien entre guillemets c'est c'est une ça
reste une goutte d'eau sur un tracé
routier aussi vaste que la déviation qui
peut se mettre en place
ici tu pourrais nous dire comment ça se
passe concrètement la fin d'un chantier
de fouille comment on ferme un chantier
euh ben on va finir de tout fouiller
donc tout les outils vont être
nettoyés vont être ramenés dans les
locaux de de de sain plus dans notre
agence la plateforme sur laquelle on on
on vit tous les jours où on a notre
réfectoire et cetera tout ça ça va être
démonté et ensuite il y a les engin
mécaniques qui vont revenir pour aplanir
finalement l'ensemble de l'emprise alors
c'est pas juste pour dépenser du gasoil
c'est parce que pour des rais Z sécurité
en fait assez évidente on a des petites
trous un petit peu partout l'idée c'est
si quelqu'un par mes gardes franchit les
barrières de sécurité et vient se
promener il faut qu'il y ait aucun
risque entre guillemets donc tout va
être mis à plat et ça te fait quoi de
retourner dans des endroits où tu as
fait des la fouille préventive genre
c'est rigolo non c'est assez amusant de
voir tu si tu passes en voiture sur
cette route ah bah oui on y pense à
chaque fois on a des collègues qu'on
fouillé sous des routes il y a 30 ans à
chaque fois qu'il passe ils y pensent
ouais ouais ça ça fait partie du jeu et
c'est rigolo parce qu'on est amené à
travailler dans plein d'endroits
différents et du coup quand on y repasse
il y a ça fait toujours bah il y a
toujours une histoire qui est associée
parce qu'on a travaillé avec une équipe
on a sorti des vestiges sympas
ouais on y pense à chaque
[Musique]
fois